[Applaudissements]
Franck de la personne
voilà
qui évidemment on le sait c'est beaucoup
mouillé pendant la campagne et qui
s'était voilà investi auprès de
2017 oui et depuis 2017 on vous le fait
payer je vous raconterai ce qui s'est
passé mais c'est pas aussi simple que ça
mais voilà
quand je suis parti je me suis dit
j'aurais dû pas venu voilà mais bon mais
sur le moment mais c'était pour des
raisons personnelles parce que j'étais
je suis à l'origine j'étais un
souverainiste de gauche donc je le
souverainise pour moi c'était important
je croyais pas à l'Europe je croyais pas
d'accord et donc quand Madame Le Pen qui
d'ailleurs a été très gentil moi je n'ai
pas de j'ai pas un mot méchant sur elle
parce que c'est très bien c'est très
bien passé mais sur le point sur le plan
de mon investissement personnel j'étais
venu pour le souverainisme et trois mois
après on me dit on est plus
souverainiste non mais ça c'est la
politique
elle a eu raison de le faire mais
probablement
et moi alors il se trouve qu'après moi
je suis rentré
j'ai eu une campagne légis arrive ou en
fait on ne s'appelait plutôt jouer
contre moi parce que justement ils m'ont
parce qu'ils ont c'est le parti de
Monsieur Le Pen qui a lutté contre moi
et qui m'a empêché d'être au second tour
19 est-ce que votre métier vous le
faites oui ça repart mon crime François
Ozon et sur la fiche et on vient de
battre cette semaine de Scream ça repart
alors président
américain président
pour tous mais c'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui
et c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui le
sujet d'aujourd'hui c'est effectivement
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure les
people suivent en général la tendance à
les people les artistes 70% des gens
sont contre la retraite donc les people
sont contre leur retraite parce qu'ils
veulent pas ne pas remplir leur salle
c'est assez simple on veut pas se mettre
les gens à dos et ils ont signé un
manifeste alors tu as du père minette tu
as jugé Binoche tu as un nombre de
personnes incroyable là-dedans c'est
très parisien très beau mais il le signe
chez eux et puis derrière ils sont ils
en ont rien à et voilà et il y a
des gens comme vous et je le dis
franchement autant la manif pour tous on
parlera on n'a pas les mêmes idées mais
on parle des retraites la retraite vous
vous descendez dans la rue vous y êtes
allé donc vous avez la police en face
vous avez les manifestants
donc vous vous investissez beaucoup
d'abord pourquoi et comment ça se passe
dans la rue véritablement tout
simplement parce que je pense que chacun
d'entre nous si nous voulons que la
démocratie vive il faut l'incarner nous
même pardon et bien donc si
effectivement on pense aujourd'hui que
le gouvernement actuel met en place une
mesure et je le dis très sincèrement qui
est inadapté injuste parce que il y a
moins de gens qui travaillent que de
machines qui les place et que j'ai
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
écrit au député notamment députés LR
pour voter la motion de censure sa
première fois qu'on avait une censure
qui était votée par les filles et le RN
pas trop de politique dans la rue je
termine juste pour dire qu'à partir de
ce moment-là il faut tout faire pour que
ce que demande le peuple advienne à
l'Assemblée voilà donc
juste quand vous descendez dans la rue
parce que nous on a des témoignages mais
je reconnais que je suis pas beaucoup
descendu dans la rue sujet facile le
mien au départ était un sujet beaucoup
plus compliqué quoique les sondages à
70% les Français étaient pour une union
homosexuelle égale en mairie mais où on
change pas la filiation des enfants
ça a parlé ça n'a pas fait ce qui est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ça brûle Paris
brûle les Français se battent contre la
police
dit que la police fait des horreurs on
dit que les gens font des horreurs il y
a des pavés qui sont lancés des
policiers disent qui reçoivent des des
balles des boules de comment ça
s'appelle donc de pétanque de pétanque
il y a des morts j'aimerais savoir vous
qui êtes dans la rue comment ça se passe
votre la police par exemple ah bah non
mais la police alors là dès que ça comme
alors je suis désolé je vous décevoir
dès que ça commence à cogner ou qu'il y
a trop de lacrymo moi c'est fini on
voilà je je ne peux pas supporter ça je
ne descends pas pour la violence la
violence et notre ennemi nous allons
perdre parce que ça va être de la faute
soit des manifestants soit de la police
soit des donc non en revanche là où
c'est très important c'est et il faut
comprendre aussi pourquoi ça se tend
c'est quand le gouvernement et le
président de la République n'entendent
pas le pays voilà merci il y en a un qui
peut dire et est-ce qu'on peut y aller
ils ne prennent pas pour toi tu peux le
dire mais moi moi j'ai une question
après j'ai une question parce que ça me
fait toujours rire les l'autre jour
j'avais des gens que je trouve charmant
j'avais un berbert Léonard tout ça et
ils viennent pas les deux retraites et
ils viennent parler d'eux mais ils
viennent parler de choses une fois que
tout a été voté soit vous parlez avant
je n'ai pas entendu un artiste cette
année quand il y a les humours quand il
y avait pas un ou un ou deux qui ont été
blacklistés j'en ai pas entendu un et
maintenant que ça arrive il nous raconte
leur retraite donc il y a aussi il y a
aussi ça il y a des causes faciles à
soutenir effectivement qui permettent à
une carrière de progresser il y a des
causes pas faciles je j'en suis d'une
représentante et là la différence de mon
ami Franck nous enfin moi je n'ai plus
enfin j'ai pu mon travail d'avant mais
est-ce que vous pensez que jamais
chroniqueur télé d'accord
je n'ai pas eu d'accident de voiture et
j'ai quand même est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous êtes toujours convaincu aussi
quand on descend dans la rue
quand on descend dans la rue et qu'on a
dû un peu d'impact sur les on a un peu
plus de pouvoir parce qu'on fait la
télévision faut quand même être sûr de
ses convictions est-ce que vous pensez
toujours que vous avez raison absolument
mais en revanche je déplore est-ce que
vous pensez toujours que vous avez
raison bien sûr Mathieu je pense
simplement que le message que je
diffusais à la tête des immenses manif
vous savez trois fois un million quand
il y a pas de syndicat c'est sur un
sujet aussi complexe que la
reconnaissance j'ai quand même entendu
aussi pardon parce que c'est pour ça que
je vous dis je vous dis ça me fait un
peu rire parce que Hénin et l'autre et
là je vais être un petit peu dur j'ai
même perdu mon appart cher non mais je
là où je suis un peu dur c'est que
l'analyse pour tous vous étiez le leader
vous avez donné à la parole à tous les
homophobes et puis un an après quand
vous attendez je finis un an après quand
vous avez vu que c'était passé vous avez
dit non on sait pas compris c'était pas
dans ce que c'était pas vraiment ça et
vous Franck magnifique
et après vous avez dit et après vous
avez dit non mais c'était une erreur
pour rebosser c'est toi qui les gars
parce que quand vous êtes souverainiste
que vous conseil pour soutenir une dame
qui a du mal à casser son plafond de
verre et vous lui dites on va essayer de
l'attaquer je vais essayer de vous aider
parce que je suis pour la démocratie et
je suis souverainiste et que trois mois
après elle décide de changer pour des
raisons politiques tout alors que moi
j'ai tout foutu dans la balance je dis
j'ai été aussi honnête avec elle que
j'ai été au début avec les autres parce
que moi je viens plutôt du monde
mélenchoniste pendant 15 ans j'ai
travaillé qu'avec des réalisateurs très
investis etc et j'y croyais en plus
il croyait mais je n'y crois plus à rien
du tout ni d'un côté ni de l'autre et
pourquoi parce que quand le
souverainisme
est-ce que vous allez continuer de
donner votre avis maintenant que vous
retravailler alors le je donnerai mon
avis sur d'une autre manière c'est à
dire que ce qui m'est arrivé j'ai été
droit dans mes bottes quand j'y suis
allé j'ai pris je savais que ça serait
ça serait dur
j'en ai parlé à ma mère qui était très
matrice souffrant très malade etc moi
après j'ai j'ai quand j'ai vu que ça
n'allait pas j'ai dit bon bah alors je
m'en vais c'est aussi simple pour moi
d'arriver que de repartir et j'ai dit je
m'en vais pour ces raisons là votre
temps pour ces raisons là je peux te
demander
l'histoire mais entre-temps tu oublies
juste de dire que tu as perdu les
élections ah oui parce qu'on m'a
présenté aux élections présidentielles
législatives voilà peut-être pas mais au
17e mais tu étais face à France écoute
dans le nord de la France et tu es
arrivé à moins de 10% tu as même pas été
sélectionné ça alors que c'est un menson
alors que c'est un bass que j'ai fait 15
97 tu as pas été sélectionné 97 ans
en ayant un pas et en ayant alors
attends
s'il te plaît je suis super content
parce que j'avais je vais vous dire
j'avais plutôt de la sympathie pour
Ruffin et ça m'embêtait un peu mis en
place pas trop politique est-ce que tu
as une
je reprends mon débat tu vas pas là
c'est par les pas des rues fin des
machins soyez pas techniques d'accord
oui alors s'il te plaît Déborah ça va
être beaucoup plus simple vous aviez
vous vous aviez merci
c'est adorable vous étiez quelle heure
est-il alors bougez pas vous étiez à la
base comédien vous avez tourné et bien
même Fabrice Éboué qui a duré un moment
vous gommer de son film pour les
positions
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans notre
tête pour vous dire et si je me mettais
à la politique
et ben je vais vous le raconter depuis
2016 je voyais des amis que très comme
ça très très bien pensant que je
fréquentais très opulent entre nous
souhaits tous ces gens-là et des gens
très opulents qui en fait tu te une
parole très consensuelle etc et en fait
ils sont je les ai j'en ai vu
quelques-uns ce conduire un peu comme
des hyènes et je me dis dans le fond ils
sont pareils là que là mais je voyais de
l'autre côté un débat un démocratique
qui se bloquait et j'arrive en 2017 à
peu près je vois la tête de Macron qui
arrive à la télé il m'est arrivé quelque
chose qui est absolument incroyable et
j'ai vécu la suite après
j'ai vu
j'ai vu le diable c'est terrible à dire
mais j'ai une vision mais pardon c'est
ma vie
intérieure j'ai vu beaucoup de choses et
ça m'a ça m'est arrivé dans ma vie et
j'ai vu un cortège de choses pas joli
des avec des choses vilaines et sur un
très longtemps vous avez voté parce que
vous avez une vision oui dans c'est ce
qui m'a déclenché pour aller où et j'ai
dit qui est en situation de combat de ce
type bah cet homme bon c'est pas lui
c'est ce qu'il représente c'est les
énergies qui sont derrière lui et je me
suis dit il faut que je trouve la
personne qui sera la mieux placée en
face si Mélenchon avait été mieux placé
j'aurais suivi Mélenchon j'ai entendu et
si c'est et puisque ça a été marine j'ai
dit
faut que tout le monde parle un petit
peu
j'ai eu un Philippe je ne savais pas du
tout je commence à bosser l'émission et
je vois Philippe Candeloro soutient Eric
Zemmour ah ouais c'était le bordel à
cause de Jordan alors moi encore une
fois ce mec qui me pose cinq fois la
dans l'émission est-ce que vous
supportez vous allez voter les émous
est-ce que vous avez cinq fois je ne
connais pas le personnage je ne connais
pas son programme je sais pas par contre
ce qui me fait marrer en tant que
sportif de niveau moi c'est qu'un mec il
arrive donne nulle part de la politique
il va venir faire chier les grands et
les ténor c'est ça que j'ai répondu j'ai
pas dit que je soutenais à xemmour bah
pour répondre à la question de partout
est-ce que ça t'a été préjudiciable oui
oui
avec qui je travaille puisqu'on fait des
prestations sur les patinoires éphémères
justement pour devant les gamins et tout
ça ils ont dit tu as vu ton pote Candel
il supporte Zemmour donc on veut plus le
voir
donc j'avais engueulé d'ailleurs Jordan
je dis parce que quand tu écoutes
l'émission on voit bien que je dis je
dis pas que je supporte Zemmour c'est le
lendemain sur TV publicitaire machin non
mais attends t'inquiète pas j'ai
beaucoup de pouvoir je suis le deuxième
après Hanouna je vais faire je vais
faire virer Jordan non
non
il s'avère que depuis le temps que moi
je depuis le temps que je sentais de ces
quatre jours un peu mais avec les dettes
Pompidou et donc je vois que
effectivement le monde culturel le monde
du spectacle le monde de la télévision
bah il est toujours avec le camp du
progrès avec le camp de la bonne pensée
et dès qu'on est à droite moi j'ai fait
les campagnes de Chirac en 88 mais c'est
un peu ce que vos proches vous avez
réfléchir vous avez fait Boutin vous
avez fait la manif pour tous l'analyse
pour tous
chaque année une frigides pas du tout
j'ai même passé de chiracles Madame
Boutin elle était contre l'union civile
elle est contre la famille homoparentale
bon bah voilà alors donc elle est pas
elle contre moi voilà tu as compris bon
et bien maintenant quand on va vers la
droite même si le peuple effectivement
comme vous le voyez le score du RN il
fallait il fallait être présenté cette
année en 2022
c'est effectivement ça te pèse pourquoi
les grandes stars ne se sont jamais
engagés pour les candidats alors Marine
Le Pen personne à part fondu à personne
et quand tu as Zemmour bon bah il y a eu
un petit loupé la salto arrière raté
pauvre Philippe je suis désolé mais en
revanche vous savez qu'il y a que Johnny
Hallyday qui soutenait Jacques Chirac
alors frigide question très précise
parce que je veux qu'on avance jamais
soutenu
se manifeste des 300 acteurs machins
terminés j'ai dit Juliette Binoche il y
en a plein des connu moins connus
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de se
manifeste de ceux qui l'ont je pense que
comme vous l'avez dit très justement
tout à l'heure c'est une cause qui est
soutenue par une immense majorité de
Français attendez que ça red génère un
peu plus peut-être qu'on verra des gens
quitter leur signature et tout d'un coup
être un peu moins favorable à cette
retraite la réforme sincèrement moi il
m'aurait appelé je les aurais soutenus
j'aurais signé aussi et je pense qu'il y
en a beaucoup là-dedans parce que j'en
connais certains qui ont je les connais
ils sont ils sont sincères dans leur
démarche la preuve moi pas non mais
voilà je veux dire il y a une sincérité
Jean-Michel
il y a forcément des stars aussi qui
sont pour la réforme et jamais ils
feront une tribune mais non
mais c'est vrai mais oui bravo bah non
j'ai fait couper le truc
moi je trouve ça très courageux de la
part des des stars des célébrités de se
positionner pour une raison toute simple
c'est que les journalistes apprennent
leur parlent que de ça on se rappelle de
Faudel et Doc Gynéco qui avait soutenu
Sarkozy ça leur a coûté leur carrière
voilà quand Vincent Lindon dans un autre
genre c'est pas vraiment un parti
politique mais quand il prend parti au
moment de la pandémie qui fait une
tribune de 15 minutes diffusée sur
Mediapart vous lui dit que les hôpitaux
sont dans un état lamentable les
journalistes pendant un an ne lui
parlent que de ça donc
à l'inverse notre l'animateur Laurent
Ruquier qui a toujours dit pour qui
votait c'est que le Royal tout ça n'a
jamais eu de soucis est-ce que est-ce
que ces gens qui prennent pas position
ce sont aussi des gens à problèmes
souvent pardon et moi frigide la seule
chose pas que je vous reproche vous
allez dans la rue et vous avez du
courage je dis bravo parce que moi j'y
vais pas non surtout qu'il y a des gens
qui me crachent dessus c'est des manifs
de gauche et ils sont pas contents
vous perdez pas c'est le quatrième
prenez un plan ouais
non non on ne passe pas les Invalides
vous avez quand même dit le mariage gay
c'est le mariage entre deux animaux mais
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
jamais j'ai écrit en octobre pour tout
le monde là tous les journalistes madame
Morini Bosc qui se connaît tout sur tout
d'ailleurs je voilà je vous souhaite une
référence
c'est ta journée
je vous trouve assez honnête quand vous
voilà quand vous dans vos argumentaires
et tout donc pardon j'avais envie de le
dire bon merci beaucoup alors c'est tout
et donc je voulais dire que sur le site
frigidmarjo.com qui existait avant que
ce monde se collectif de mais qui
n'existe plus toute façon il existe pas
que mon assaut l'avenir pour tous et
sinon leur syndicat de la famille de la
famille c'est pas pareil moi je défends
les familles et bien
j'écrivais en octobre 2012 qu'en fin
nous pourrions demander un référendum à
la population ça c'est pour que
écoute-moi bien pour qu'il y ait un
grand débat sur la remise en cause de la
filiation biologique voilà c'était ça
comment il s'appelle Patrick Morandini
je lui ai dit Gérard Gérard Morandini je
lui ai dit
le Code civil l'artiste qui disait avant
la loi Taubira le mariage
conclut entre un homme et une rigidité
avant 18 ans
est-ce que je peux vous poser une
question vous avez parfaitement le droit
de penser ce que vous voulez et encore
une fois tout le monde peut vous dire
NON NON tout le monde s'invite je dis
juste est-ce que vous regrettez juste
cette phrase là que vous avez dites un
mariage entre deux hommes c'est comme
Marie deux animaux c'est faux j'ai dit
exactement s'il y a plus le meilleur
femme
et femme on en est au non binarismo au
troisième sexe au troisième genre c'est
la journée de la visibilité du
transgenre il y aura plus d'hommes et de
femmes donc on pourra y mettre ce qu'on
veut et pourquoi pas des animaux j'ai
paniqué ils ont pas sexuels
le président de l'avenir pour tous c'est
gay
on va finir par le président gay non non
non
[Applaudissements]
malgré tout malgré tout il faut avoir
des gens qui ont du courage parler c'est
facile agir c'est mieux c'est Simone
Veil qui le disait donc voilà c'est
quand même important et je voudrais
finir aussi en mode en quoi
bien sûr
[Rires]
des deux bouquins de frigides à acheter
ou pas